I think Google glass could be an
incredible technology one of my grad
students that's working at the lab is
working on a simultaneous subtitle
translation application for movies so
you could go into a movie and be a
spanish-speaking person you could go
into an english-language movie and it
would show you the subtitles on the
Google glass while you're watching the
movie that to me would be very cool and
if we could do it in seven or eight
languages that would be a fabulous
application for and and maybe even for
people who are hard of hearing you could
you could do that and it has a little
you know bone conductor in the back of
the thing so you could feel the shake of
the buildings in an action movie but
also see the you know english subtitles
so to speak but that being said I also
think that if I was at a really
interesting political dinner party say
and someone had google glass on would I
be as honest and open and you know just
completely loose especially after a
bottle of wine as as I would if they
didn't have google glass on I'm not sure
I would you because I wouldn't be sure
Will are they recording me I'm like you
know am I going to regret what I'm
saying you know so that's that's an
interesting question
you